j'ai des visions
la police a retrouvé le corps du docteur
florence weaver sauvagement assassinée à
son domicile ce matin tu la connais
c'est non mais je les ai vus mourir
gevrey des choses
j'assiste à des meurtres pendant qu'ils
sont commis
j'ai quelqu'un
il a dit qu'il s'appelait gabriel
je crois que c'est quelqu'un pour passer
je ne sais pas ce que tu as vécu avant
de rejoindre notre famille mais tu as
souffert d'une façon que je suis
incapable d'imaginer
[Musique]
je ne sais pas ce que c'était mais c'est
chose est revenu ce
qu'il a encore tué il se rapproche
il veut vous dire quelque chose
maman qu'est ce que tu sais
[Applaudissements]
qu'il veut s'en prendre à moi
du chic
[Musique]